is where it all happened May 27th two
days after the killing of George Floyd
the Auto Zone which is right here burned
to the ground that was August of 2020 I
was standing right here in this spot
with a torch police precinct over one
shoulder and the burned down Auto Zone
over the other
it was just 10 weeks after the George
Floyd riots that destroyed so much of
this area I decided to come back every
summer to find out what's changing is
the crime getting better or getting
worse is there a police presence here
that's trusted and what about this third
police precinct that was burned down
during the riots
does it remain a monument to Anarchy
we decided to talk to a number of people
in different walks of life what do they
think thoughts looking at the old third
police precinct building three years
after the riots it brings back a lot of
bad memories for certainly myself but
also obviously uh the police officers
that once worked out of the facility so
it's it's just sad to see here we are
three years later and literally nothing
has changed
cat girlicker is a retired Minneapolis
Police Officer he was one of the
commanders who led the police response
after George Floyd's death the last two
years really have been off the hook as
it relates to violent crime in
Minneapolis and there there have been
signs of progress in some areas and some
anti-violence initiatives but having
said that crime certainly still is high
and anytime you have over 400 fewer
officers than you had before it really
is difficult to get a handle on Street
crime it doesn't look like there is
going to be a police precinct in this
actual area that suffered so much after
the Floyd riots the activists I think
believe that's a Surrender by the police
or the city council they consider it a
victory oh I totally agree I think the
activists and some of the city council
members who are also activists
themselves considered a victory not to
have police in the precinct because some
of the city council don't want police to
begin with their agenda is to eliminate
the police their agenda is to disrupt
Law and Order they thrive on that the
residents however if you talk to the
residents I'm sure you have they really
want to see the police in their own
Community it's been a tough couple years
Mark wellna is the owner of wellna Ace
Hardware and it's a business that's been
in his family for 70 years
but life here isn't easy it's getting
harder crime and frankly a lack of
political leadership doesn't help I
noticed you have blocked you've blocked
off some of the aisles why is that we
have to help people down those aisles
because we just had too much theft
because in the tool area you know a lot
of the thieves that are breaking into
houses around here they can't even buy
the tools of their trade they have to
steal the crowbars and screwdrivers
we've had propane tanks that you
exchange for your grills we had all 18
of them stolen one night homeless
encampments have been a problem across
this part of the Cities how has that
impacted the running of this family
business there's a lot of trash
a lot of needles all over our
neighborhood
like one of the young men that cuts the
lawn in the neighborhood in most
neighborhoods you pick up the the sticks
and twigs before you cut the lawn he had
to pick up 20 needles that were in his
yard we had the encampments and stuff
like that
I'm listening half a block away from
some of this stuff so I had to pick up
stuff from that here
unnecessary things that shouldn't have
to happen Tony Williams grew up in this
area and he's noticed a lot of changes
like when we grew up we had every race
around this neighborhood had nados black
white hispanic monk Jamaican we had all
together we hang out with every other
spot every house it was all together
all the time something has changed I
don't know what
I think that something did happen some
of the folks we talked to are really
trying to make a difference in the
community and saw real reason for
optimism but then there were others who
were long-time residents who see the
fault not only with City officials and
political leadership
but with the community itself we as
African-American Community you have to
Rico okay we got to rake up and be more
aware because everybody that sitting
there for us is not up not for us you
got people like Al sharper lying their
pockets every time somebody get killed
he fly in town we got to be more wise
and see who do we vote for it's not
about democrat or republican we got to
read the issues and study the issues and
say has anything changed our quality of
life ain't nothing changed since I've
been up here it's sad to say you have
you have more African-American churches
you know they always want to say it's
the white man's fault it's the white
man's fault how about we say sometimes
it's the black man's fault this is our
community ain't no white folks come in
our community putting trash ain't no
white Community
killing it's us killing each other it's
called black on black crime
but it's black on black crime it's a
shame we pumping all this money this
country has published all this money
into trying to get the African-American
communities back on track is not
happening where's the money going we
still got potholes over here if you come
back next year this city will still look
the same all across Chicago San
Francisco and all over it's not only in
Minneapolis it's all over it's like a
way
well we like to get out of the studio
and talk to real people we learn a lot
when we do that America is a great place
and it deserves great leadership hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else